et les étudiants de Tepper dans le fond,
ceci va vous intéresser.
Nous avons constaté que les mots de passe créés
par des personnes affiliées à l'école d'informatique
étaient en fait 1,8 fois plus difficiles
que ceux des personnes affiliées à l'école de commerce.
Nous avons également beaucoup d'autres
informations démographiques très intéressantes.
L'autre chose très intéressante que nous avons constatée
est que lorsque nous avons comparé les mots de passe de Carnegie Mellon
avec ceux générés par Mechanical Turk,
il y avait beaucoup de similitudes,
et ça a contribué à valider notre méthode de recherche
et montre qu'en fait, collecter des mots de passe
en utilisant les études de Mechanical Turk
est une façon valide d'étudier les mots de passe.
C'étaient donc de bonnes nouvelles.
OK, pour finir je voudrais parler de
d'aperçus que j'ai eu alors que j'étais en année sabbatique
l'année dernière à l'école d'art de Carnegie Mellon.
Une des choses que j'ai faites
est que j'ai fait nombre de couettes,
et j'ai fait cette couette-ci.
Elle s'appelle la « couverture de sécurité ».
(Rires)
Et sur cette couette il y a les 1 000
mots de passe les plus fréquemment volés
du site RockYou.
Et la taille des mots de passe est proportionnelle
à leur fréquence d'apparition
dans la base de données des vols.
Ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai créé ce nuage de mots
et j'ai parcouru ces 1 000 mots
et je les ai classés
en catégories thématiques.
Et, dans certains cas,
il a été assez difficile de déterminer
dans quelle catégorie ils devraient être,
et ensuite j'ai créé un code couleur.
Voici des exemples de la difficulté.
« Justin ».
Est-ce le nom de l'utilisateur,
de son copain, de son fils ?
Peut-être que c'est juste un fan de Justin Bieber.
Ou « princesse ».
Est-ce un surnom ?
Est-ce un fan des princesses de Disney ?
Ou peut-être que c'est le nom de leur chat.
« Jetaime » apparaît de nombreuses fois
dans de nombreuses langues.
Il y a beaucoup d'amour dans ces mots de passe.
Si vous regardez attentivement, vous verrez également
quelques obscénités,
mais pour moi il était très intéressant de voir
qu'il y a beaucoup plus d'amour que de haine
dans ces mots de passe.
Il y a des animaux,
beaucoup d'animaux,
et « singe » est l'animal le plus commun
et le 14ème mot de passe le plus populaire de tous.
Et cela m'a paru curieux,
et je me suis demandé : « Pourquoi les singes sont-il si populaires ? »
Donc dans notre dernière étude sur les mots de passe,
à chaque fois que nous détections quelqu'un
qui créait un mot de passe contenant le mot « singe »,
nous leur demandions pourquoi ils avaient « singe » dans leur mot de passe.
Et nous avons constaté --
jusqu'ici nous avons trouvé 17 personnes, je crois,
qui ont le mot « singe » --
Nous avons remarqué qu'environ un tiers d'entre eux disait
qu'ils avaient un animal de compagnie qui s'appelait « singe »
ou un ami surnommé « singe »,
et environ un tiers d'entre eux disait
que c'était juste qu'ils aimaient les singes
et que les singes sont très mignons.
Et celui-ci est vraiment mignon.
Il semble qu'en fin de compte,
quand nous créons nos mots de passe,
nous faisons soit quelque chose de très simple
à taper, un schéma familier,
ou quelque chose qui nous rappelle l'expression « mot de passe »
ou le compte pour lequel nous avons créé le mot de passe,
ou quoi que ce soit.
Ou nous pensons à des choses qui nous rendent heureux,
et nous créons notre mot de passe
à partir de choses qui nous rendent heureux.
Et, alors que ça rend plus amusant le fait de taper
et de se souvenir de notre mot de passe,
ça rend aussi nos mots de passe
plus facilement devinables.
Je sais que beaucoup de ces exposés de TED
sont source d'inspiration
et qu'ils vont font penser à des choses sympas et heureuses,
mais quand vous créez votre mot de passe,
essayez de penser à quelque chose d'autre.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)